nice question sandy how can you change
the energy of a show if the audience is
tight besides getting them to applaud
themselves
or the venue great question
i think how it can change getting them
to applaud themselves
in the venue is a good icebreaker but
i think beyond that just set the
expectations
if the audience is tight you can address
it in a fun and playful way if you're
not
attacking the audience about what's
wrong with y'all that's such a big
young comic mistake blaming the audience
uh off stage blaming the audience or
more importantly
on stage berating the audience for them
not laughing like the comic wants them
to
as a host you can do this as a comic
doing a set as well but address the
elephant in the room if you're a host
and they're seemingly tight and this may
be at the beginning of the show when
audience is typically tighter
let them know what we're doing here you
know hey it's a it's a tuesday night
we're here at a comedy show we get to
witness
live comedy entertainment in its purest
form we're so excited to have y'all make
some noise for yourselves for coming out
you could have stayed at home and watch
netflix but you're here
watching some of comedy's future stars
like
really make the event feel
special really make that moment you're
all
sharing as special as it truly is
because you think i mean live comedy
that's like the
i mean in my opinion i mean that's like
art in its purest
form when you're live and it's raw and
we don't
know what's going to happen and the
audience is there in anticipation
and just remind the audience you know
hey this is a comedy show you know we
didn't come
come here to not laugh you know i mean
we're here to laugh this is a comedy
show you're allowed to and what i've
even done before
i've gotten the audience to practice
laughing
that's another good way just to warm
them up it's like we're going to be
laughing we got some of the
future stars of comedy let's uh let me
hear uh let's hear some practice
laughter let's get let's get out of get
it out of our system now and then like
you can laugh along with them and you
can make it a communal experience
but i think the more you can frame the
show
as this unique moment you're all sharing
together the more you can start
to shift that energy in the room thanks
for watching this clip if you found
these tips helpful and you want to get
involved in our hosting workshop
go into the show description and request
to join
our hot breath pro facebook group if
you're looking to level up your comedy
that is the group for you